if you want to consistently make money
trading these five scalping patterns are
all you're going to need I've used them
in my own trading strategy for years
making thousands in profits just from
these patterns now we'll start with some
of the more basic foundational patterns
that are crucial to the more complex
ones and then we'll build into the
higher win rate ones that are going to
make you the most money so the first
pattern I want to start off with is a
head and shoulders pattern now this
pattern is really basic and even if you
are already kind of know what this
pattern is there's a couple keys to this
pattern that I found over time that are
really important and also keys that
aren't as important as other people
might think when the reality comes to
actually trading this now if you don't
know what this pattern is the basic idea
is it's a reversal pattern we're looking
at a bearish version and what that means
is you're looking at the market to in an
uptrend to actually reverse and so how
the pattern works is it's basically just
the market is moving up and up Trend
it's making higher highs and it's making
higher lows and then all of a sudden it
makes a low here that's kind of the same
and then it actually makes a lower low
and so essentially what you're looking
at is kind of a head here with two
shoulders kind of you know a person and
so that's why it gets that head and
shoulders name but the main thing you're
looking at here is often you have
something right here called the neckline
and so what that means is well you're
starting to see some bearish pattern
here because we've made a lower high
right here and that's a signal that the
Market's not as strong anymore if it was
still strong this High here would have
you know made a newer high but instead
it didn't and so the idea is when it
breaks this neckline here or essentially
this double bottom that the Market's
made it's going to you know flush lower
and that signals a you know a good spot
to either buy betting the Mark's going
to go down and and that it's going to go
down from there now the re ity of this
pattern you know it doesn't always show
up you know any of these patterns
doesn't really show up like that you
know a lot of the times it kind of looks
a little different right but here you
can kind of see the same thing we have a
move up just kind of looking at the
swings it's made kind of a bigger swing
there and then here it makes a a lower
swing here and then it makes a lower
high and so the main thing is you're
kind of looking at these three swing
highs here how they relate to each other
and then you can also look at these lows
and this being a lower low right here I
actually think makes the pattern even
stronger because it's already showing
you that it's shifting into a lower low
lower high kind of downtrend which then
is a good signal for you know this
breaking lower here now some keys to
this pattern that I think you want to
pay attention to is you want going into
the pattern and we'll look at some real
examples of this later to show you more
and you know kind of not just a small
picture like this you want there to be a
big move up into the pattern and so what
this does is it allows there to be
essentially a gap in the market of an
unhealthy move that when it starts to
come up here do this head and shoulders
pattern that when it does break lower
it's likely to give that move back up
which is very important for you as a
Trader trying to actually profit from
this pattern if it doesn't have that
it's more likely to just kind of sit
around and chop and you know maybe
reverses a little bit but it's not as
good as a a profitable opportunity and
that's the key when it comes to these
trading these patterns is that you can
actually profit from them and then the
other thing is having larger than normal
rejection bars like here you can see
from that kind of final swing High
essentially the head of the head and
shoulders pattern shows you a more
stronger change and shift of momentum
you know here you kind of have it had a
big bullish candle here and then a
reversal but they kind of kept going up
and then here it just with the final
move up it had a much stronger rejection
and so that really shows that the market
is starting to shift and that's what you
want to be doing with these patterns is
you want to be reading into what the
candles look like versus kind of just
saying okay well it's you know kind of
fitting the theory here and so to shift
to kind of what this looks like in more
of a reversal bullish to the long side
and also some unimportant factors now
this I'm looking at is an actual PDF
that you can download and it will go
through a lot of these patterns we're
going to talk about I'm going to
obviously go into more detail here and
there's a couple of patterns later in
the video that aren't in this PDF but
definitely go in the link in the
description of this video and download
this PDF it'll be really good for you to
just you know come back look and even
just glance at what are these
unimportant factors for this and so to
flip this on the bullish side this is
just you're betting that the market is
you know in a downtrend that it's going
to find some support and reverse back up
and so you know it just looks like that
on the flip side where it's just the
instead you're looking at the lows and
you have the lows are starting to from
shifting from lower lows they start
shifting to a higher low and then you
can have this neckline right here as
well and so the reality and an
unimportant Factor kind of brushed in
this in the last one is you don't need
this neckline it does not have to be
flat like this it can be other ways and
kind of like the last one too is just
looking at this is from The Head and
Shoulders pattern here you have your
lows and you can see that I think
because this is a higher low than this
one that's kind of confirming the head
and shoulders but also having this swing
High here be higher than this last swing
high again it's it's even more
confirmation that it's shifting from a
downwards trend into making lower lows
and lower highs into an upwards Trend
where where it's making higher highs and
higher lows and that's essentially just
drawing that right here that's
essentially a head and shoulders right
there that's what they look like and so
it's it's kind of just the raw basics of
looking at Price action and reading the
market and so you know unimportant
factors that neckline it does not need
to be flat and then the other
unimportant factor is that the head of
the head and shoulders it doesn't have
to be way farther than the other
swings from the shoulders you can see
here these are pretty much the same
price and so it's almost like a triple
bottom but it's it's still showing you
that importance that the market is
bottoming here and it's and even with
this one right here this Candlestick
shows you a really good rejection this
Candlestick essentially shows you the
market opened here sold off attempted to
keep going lower but the strength of the
market came in here and pushed it back
higher and so it then rever reversed up
and then kind of close kind of here and
then the next candle you can see just
kind of was a massive green candle shot
higher and that kind of is how the head
and shoulders works and I would like to
get in basically here because I think
this red Candlestick is a good enough
confirmation and you know obviously I I
have other things in my checklist but
that would be where I would get in Long
looking for the market to reverse and
again going back to that important
factor you can see here's another
example of there is a nice flush lower
and a move lower that it makes it likely
for when you do get in there's
profitable move in this trade now the
next pattern is another reversal pattern
and it's called a reversal flag and so
this is very similar to head and
shoulders in terms of the theory you
know in this case it can look like a
triple top but the idea is you know
again this is a bear so we're we're
betting that the an upwards trend is
actually going to reverse down and
instead what you're looking at a lot of
the time the main theory of this pattern
is it's just in an uptrend and then it
just starts to sit there showing you
that that momentum of the uptrend has
dwindled and it's starting to slow down
that's a lots similar to The Head and
Shoulders pattern but the head and
shoulders pattern is a lot more volatile
in a way instead of the reality this is
it just comes up it has good momentum
and all of a sudden it just kind of
starts sitting there and the key to this
is looking at the Candlestick you have
that big move up with big bullish
candlesticks and then looking at all
these it's just starting to kind of sit
there there's a lot of dois there's a
lot of just essentially back and forth
movement and that just shows you that
the market has just lost its Steam and
where you want to be using this you
don't want to just use this randomly you
want to be using this in areas where you
think there is a let's say there's a big
resistance Zone up here that's what you
want to couple this with you think okay
I already think that the Market's going
to reverse here it's slammed up into
this level and then started to sit here
well that gives it another reason that
it's likely to lose steam sellers are
going to come in and then push this down
and then because you've had that big run
up into that level you're likely to
capture a profitable trade because
there's movement in the market available
now keys to this pattern is like I said
you want strong movement into that level
basically you're essentially looking for
the market to be exhausted here lose
that momentum and reverse back down for
you now another thing is essentially
it's going from one direction to
sideways you know that's just the basics
of a pattern that's actually why it's
called a flag a lot of the times because
it essentially the market just moves up
and sits here and that kind of looks
like a a flag you can also again flip
this to the reversal flag of that other
side a bullish version where again it's
coming down into an area it's showing
you some loss of momentum there's a lot
of dois there's candles that are just
back and forth you know basically it
switches from you having a lot of red
candles to there's green there's green
there's red there's green and so it's
it's just back and forth and there's a
lot of Wicks all over the place
essentially there's not much movement
and then essentially with that you're
looking for there to be essentially a
small range here and then you
essentially are buying the breakout of
that range and so you're then betting
once it breaks that you're going to it's
going to give back up whatever move it
had down that's kind of a a common
Target I use we'll talk about that a
little more later with a real example
and then some unimportant factors is you
know that it consolidates in a box
perfectly you know it doesn't have to be
where the lows and the highs are
perfectly flat and even in a nice little
range it can be all over the place a
little the main thing is that it's it's
sitting in somewhat of a range compared
to the Head and Shoulders is you don't
need clear swings in here you can kind
of see their swings but again just kind
of looking at it with you know almost
blurred eyes is a good way to sometimes
think about it is it's just kind of
sitting there and chopping around you
know you don't need to read into every
little movement of each Candlestick all
the time sometimes there's important
times to do it like with that last Head
and Shoulders example but with this one
you don't need to now one important
thing that isn't on here is that if it
starts to just sit there for a long time
then it's just lost all momentum and
it's actually not worth a good trade
this is something that will save you
money in terms of taking bad trades if
it comes down here you know you're it's
at a support level where you expect a
bounce and it starts to sit here you
know it looks good if it breaks out for
a little while but then it just starts
to kind of continue to sit there that's
when I start to say okay I'm not
interested anymore it's lost all sort of
momentum at that point it gets more
likely to where it's either going to
fake out One Direction and then keep
going lower or you know it'll fake to
the low side and then keep going higher
and so that's kind of when I start to
shift how I approach this because it's
more likely that it's it's kind of just
used its Steam and there's more of an
equilibrium of buyers and sellers at
this area versus what we're looking for
here is there to be an overextension of
either the sellers or buyers and it's
going to have that snap back that we can
profit from now the next pattern I want
to go into is called the three line
strike pattern now this is more of a
smaller Candlestick pattern but the idea
is I use it a lot for entering in with
these patterns that we've just seen so
you can kind of couple this with these
other patterns and so the theory here is
this is the bear side we're looking so
essentially we're in an uptrend and
we're looking for a signal to go to the
short side and essentially all this is
is there is a consistent uptrend and
then all of a sudden you have have a big
reversal giving back all of those
candles now the theory is you know that
it's it's you know a couple candlesticks
and one Candlestick gives them all back
you don't always need that sometimes it
can be two candlesticks but the main
idea is you know again we're looking at
the price movement what is the price
doing and here the price is showing you
that it was in a nice methodical move up
and then all of a sudden the momentum
switched and it gave that back up and we
like to in terms of reversal trading
switches the momentum s and changes in
volatility like that are really good
because a lot of time it catches a lot
of Traders off guard that are you know
in trades betting the Market's going to
go up and they have to get out of their
trade fast and it will flush lower
making a good profit and so you know it
can sometimes be where it's in kind of a
chill slow uptrend and then you get a
couple of dois where it's just starting
to sit there you know you could read
into the candle 6 and say a little bit
maybe this is kind of you know like that
flag pattern that we just talked about
where it's just kind of going up it's
losing that momentum and then you have
that big shift and so that's essentially
What's Happening Here is this is a nice
confirmation of saying okay wow that
shift is happening you know it's it's
having this basically this three line
strike pattern and I can get in at kind
of the low or the close of this candle
and bet the Market's going to go lower
and so that's a really nice confirmation
now keys to this pattern of course is
don't use it by itself and really with
any of these patterns don't use them by
themselves you can't just go into a
chart and you know see a couple things
and then just buy right you have to have
this you know coupled with uh support
level or resistance level in this case
for a short and then if this was
combined with you know a big head and
shoulders pattern or this is just the
right side shoulder this is a great
trade to get in on because you're you
know going into a resistance level and
then you have this head and shoulders
pattern and then you have this
Candlestick triggering for you here to
get in now another key is you want this
Candlestick to be big it helps that it
gives back a couple of the previous
moves of the candles or just the size
comparison is much bigger than the last
few candles cuz again it shows you that
switch in momentum now on the bullish
side same thing is you know the reality
is sometimes it can be a bunch of
candles that take a while and then boom
you have a massive reversal and so some
sometimes in these cases when the
Candlestick is this big it can be kind
of hard or scary to get in cuz it feels
like you're kind of chasing but if the
other factors are there of there's a big
gap and you know your target is way up
here you know that is that can be really
worth the trade to get in you know some
of those trades move really fast and are
very favorable to get in now unimportant
factors of this again are kind of it
doesn't matter as much of what the
candlesticks look like leading up to it
the main thing is it's kind of showing
you a slow momentum or a certain speed
of momentum and then that there is a
massive switch in momentum and the other
thing is it doesn't matter which
Candlestick makes the low you know in
this case is this Candlestick is making
the low or this Candlestick is you know
making the extreme High it doesn't have
to be like that you know in this real
case right here this dogee candle
actually made the low and then the next
candle which didn't have as low of a low
it ripped higher and you know know again
the pattern is still valid so you don't
need to get try don't try and get bogged
down in those little details the main
thing is understanding the main
psychology and price movement of what is
going on in these patterns and what
they're telling you about the market now
let's get into some of the more complex
ones and the first one here is a trap or
what I like to call in another way a
failed breakout and the theory behind
this essentially is you have a a
resistance level here and the market
comes up to this level and an uptrend
starts to slow this is actually kind of
a great example of if it you know the
market came up here and started just
chopping along and it got too choppy to
where we didn't want to you know use
that flag reversal pattern to break
lower and so we kind of were sitting and
waiting this is what you would use in
that next step to where the market
sitting here it's it's butting up into
this level and it actually breaks
through and so a lot of the times you'll
have breakout Traders and or people that
already bet short because they see this
level and so they have their you know
their stop loss here and so it'll break
that level essentially get those people
out of their trade there'll be other
people that get in here saying wow I
like this to break to the upside you
know it's already in an uptrend trend is
your friend I want to play with the
trend and I think this is going to keep
going higher they'll get in long as well
and instead the market you know not
every time but when the Stu does happen
the market decides to switch flip on
those people so all these people that
bought long are now losing money as this
goes down and who knows where their
stops are maybe they're here maybe
they're down here I don't know and then
the other people that we betting are now
seeing this and wanting to get back in
you know the people that were betting
short over here they are seeing it come
back in and they're going to want to get
in and so that's kind of a double whammy
of it has more likelihood to then push
the market lower and continue that
reversal and so I like to get in once it
kind of confirms that it's kind of a
fail breakout like this and so here's
kind of a more reality right example
here is a good example of that kind of
just consolidation where it's just
sitting there and it's just lost all
momentum and it's not worth trying to go
any One Direction and instead it starts
to have a breakout here and then boom it
has a big flush Candlestick there this
is actually a great example of that
three line strike pattern you can see it
here very clearly with nice move up here
and then that big Candlestick giving
back all of that and so that is a really
nice signal that buyers are kind of
getting screwed here and it's more
likely that it's going to push lower and
this is actually an example from a real
trade I've taken and it had a big um
uptrend right here and so my target was
to give that Trend back up and you know
um so I actually got in um I waited a
little bit more I didn't want to get in
at the low of this candle I actually
wanted to see how it kind of responded
but I believe I ended up getting in
somewhere here um I have example of a
trade on on the channel somewhere but
you know got in there it chopped a
little bit for a little bit longer but
for me the confirmation of more
likelihood to reverse was up here and so
then it you know it it moved lower from
there and so keys to this pattern is
it's best that this move is not normal
that it's not just if you have you know
let's say if you have a support level or
resistance level up here excuse me and
you know you're just in an uptrend right
here and it's just continuing higher
this is not a potential fail breakout as
likely because it's just kind of in the
same methodical Move versus this one
what looked more like this it had kind
of a move up like this it's kind of
sitting here you've already noticed that
okay the trend is already shifting it's
already gone from up to sideways and
then it has this very fast move here
that shows essentially that okay it's
it's something's changed you know
something's different and so I always
find that having that kind of
overextension of the current Trend and
and it it we'll talk about this more in
a minute of kind of an exhaustive move
it causes it to be more likely to
reverse in the other way and the other
key is that it kind of happens pretty
quick you don't want this thing to break
out and then come back and you know
start to find some higher support
because that makes it more likely that
it's just going to keep going higher you
want it to be where it's clearly tried
to break out and then all of a sudden
it's flushed back lower the more severe
and quick that is with no pullbacks like
here you can see green candle green
green green green and then red red red
and it it doesn't have to be one massive
Candlestick like this we'll look at some
examples but having it kind of be more
of one directional is a lot stronger and
so on the flip side because you you can
have this on the long or short side as
well same thing here you know you can
see the Market's kind of just sitting
here trying to find some support and and
you know not really sure which way it's
going to go and then all of a sudden you
have a big Candlestick shift lower here
I like to often think of it as a an
attempt to keep going lower and that
attempt fails and reverses hard in this
case it's a a big one Candlestick in the
One Direction and that's also really
good too because it shows you how much
the market is overextended in this case
to the low side and before here because
it's so choppy like this for so long I
often find when it goes from chop to Big
Move like that it's often more likely to
snap back and so in this case it kind of
snap back you know I think it's it's
kind of confirmed once it kind of gets
up here and then you know it kind of
continues to shoot up because it's now
had that Catalyst as you could call it
to break it out of this this kind of
dull you know doing nothing mode that
it's in something is clearly changed
here and so it's going to reverse and
shift from there and so some unimportant
factors that you don't really need to
pay attention to that I at least I don't
is the volume of the breakouts you know
I've tried looking at volume but I think
trading keep it as simple as possible
and I've always found that whenever I
try and add volume to look at something
like this I've tried it a few times and
it just honestly it just adds confusion
and in reality if you're just in tune
with the market and and following these
patterns correctly it's going to you
know these snaps work out really well
and then the next thing is it doesn't
necessarily have to break a major
support you're looking at sometimes you
can see that let's say our support Zone
that we're looking at is kind of like
this and so the Market's kind of already
bottoming here and then it has a break
lower here and and it reverses and so it
Tech you know it technically doesn't
break the low of you know if if we have
a big move down here that's where kind
of that low is drawn and then it's kind
of come here and then snap back lower it
doesn't need to break this low to be
considered a failed breakout or a trap
in this case what I'm just looking for
is that it's had this kind of chop and
it's made this move and then reversed
that is really what you're looking for
and that's going to be what shifts it
really fast in one Direction now the
last pattern here is not on that sheet
but I've kind of talked about a little
bit is when the market is overextended
or OV exhausted and so in this case this
is a great example from just a couple
days ago I'm looking at the 5 minute
Nasdaq futures right here again like you
can trade this on any marketer time
frame cuz again you're only reading
you're reading into the candlesticks and
those transcend all markets and assets
you know because it's a reflection of
what's going on underneath the hood and
so for this going into this day this is
essentially the where the market opened
and so I'm looking at you know the it's
the Market's kind of been in in kind of
a sloppy uptrend but in terms of zones
and levels I'm looking at okay there is
a resistance Zone up here and you know
support low down here but the main thing
we're looking at is it's come up here
it's kind of chopped and then it's come
up here and it's made a high and so I'm
looking at you know we're kind of at a
high here
and you know as it kind of moved up I I
think I I shifted this up a little just
to kind of look at the highs more but
essentially I'm looking at you know I
think we could come up here and reverse
and you know give this back up and and
and go all the way down here and so now
going into a one minute chart because
that's what I trade the market for me
opens up at 7:30 and you can see it kind
of just started to chop here you know
and so there's nothing really
interesting to do there you just got to
sit and wait because because you don't
want to be training in that chop it's
just not worth the risk and then all of
a sudden the market just starts to kind
of Skyrocket here and you can see that
that's really fast in one direction
we've been in kind of a chop we're now
broken out of the the highs that we were
looking at here you know this is
essentially if I zoom forward on this as
well this is essentially breaking out of
these highs from the previous night
actually and so it's broken out of the
previous highs and it's a massive move
out of nowhere it kind of felt like and
so for me I'm thinking that this is
likely to then snap back and reverse and
give that backup especially because it's
it's kind of a failed breakout and it's
also giving us that one directional move
now my candlesticks on my charts are
white and blue but these you know be
they would be all they're all the same
you know they're all bullish
candlesticks and then from there kind of
going forwards is it has that kind of
big snap back and it starts to kind of
pull back from there and now it has one
more kind of pullback here and now this
is a pattern that I I didn't really talk
about much in this video but I'll talk
about later in other videos this is kind
of just essentially a lower high it's
kind of a pullback and then from there
it's a great signal to get in short cuz
it's kind of showing you that okay the
market big strong move it tried to make
a pullback here you know if it was
strong and an uptrend it would have kept
going up here but instead that reversed
and you can see it's almost like a three
line strike pattern here uh giving back
these kind of two two candles and and
most of this third one right here too
and so from there you know then it just
kind of puked lower and then big
picture- wise is it you know gave back
that whole move all the way to the other
end of this range it was in and so
that's kind of how I look at trading
these big swings in the markets a and
using these patterns now let me show you
this on a small real account so you can
show that you can start with a small
account use these kind of moves and
patterns to your benefit and grow a
trading account and so just to remind
you that if you want that PDF just get
in the description below it'll walk
through all those kind of pages we
looked at and it's actually got a bunch
more in there as well I didn't go
through the whole thing and so just
looking at right here pause the video
and kind of think about what patterns
you're seeing that we just went over
there's a couple here that you can see
so I'm just going to give a couple
seconds just pause it and just kind of
see if you can see what these patterns
are and then from there to kind of walk
you through what I'm seeing is you know
we kind of have a big support excuse me
resistance level here and the markets
come up in you know kind of just a
methodical uptrend right and then all of
a sudden we have a massive move up
causing in my mind a a big shift you
know this is out of nowhere the the
trend was clearly just kind of chugging
along to its thing and then boom it has
a big move and so for me that's a switch
switch in what's going on an OV
exhaustion usually and so from there it
moves up pulls back has one more attempt
higher here and then kind of to zoom in
on this area looking at these
candlesticks as well is there's a three
line strike pattern here it kind of
shows up a little funky but you know
it's pretty much just a couple of
sideways candles and then it slowly
moves up and then over this Candlestick
here it moves up and reverses and then
the next candle it just gives it back up
and so for me I you know waited to see a
couple candlesticks how it responded you
know that's kind of the intricacies of
getting in short and just playing these
strategies over time you'll kind of see
how you like to play in a couple spots
but then I entered in on a trade there
put my stop loss above here because my
thought is hey if it comes up here I
just want to get out you know this is
obviously a strong move if it's going to
keep going higher it's going to go
pretty quickly or if it if it reverses
and gives back this move up I like it's
going to happen quickly as well because
these moves they generally happen
quickly and so this is again on a small
account I'm risking about $100 here
maybe a little even under I don't quite
remember but the big thing I'm looking
for here is zooming it forwards a bit is
I went to break even here once it kind
of gets moving in my favor and you know
you can see I drew this support box
because my thing is I'm thinking that
it's going to a lot of times like we
talked about earlier with these targets
or with these moves a good Target is it
gives back this kind of overextend
extension or overe exhaustive move that
happens a lot of the time and once it
kind of gives back there then it's kind
of you know it's back more in
equilibrium and you know I for me my
Edge is gone you know I I have a good
understanding of how these move I don't
have a good understanding of how they
move after but that's okay right you
only need one or two patterns to be
consistently profitable trading and so
this is my pattern right and so for me I
liked the idea of scaling out of my
trade this is a little more advanced but
I you know broke up my stop losses of
saying okay I want to get out of you
know three out of five of my contracts
right here if it decides to snap back
quickly and then I also want to just
kind of give this other one a little
more wiggle room if it's going to bounce
here and then keep going lower you know
this can be a big switch in the overall
trend and so I want to give it a little
room you know as you can see I moved it
down there I do kind of have a kind of
mental stop in my head now I quickly
moved it back but you can see I'm kind
of I'm trying to give it a couple of
candlesticks of a pullback here and then
most likely I'll move it down once it
kind of starts to reverse or you know
kind of gets to either 1X my risk you
know the idea is I want to give it some
wiggle room but I don't want to try and
give it you know give this whole swing
back up and so kind of it starts to
reverse there and so I'm going to move
my stop down now because this is kind of
a a little micro top you know I think if
it's going to make this little micro
double top and keep going lower that's a
great spot for my stop because if it
breaks this you know I think it's you
know it's it's kind of not doing what
I'm looking for and that's how I like to
manage my trade is if it's doing what I
want and so from there you know it just
kind of chopped around a little bit and
looks like it was breaking lower here
and so it starts to break lower I'm
moving my stop down and again it's still
kind of in this range you can see here
and this kind of looks like a little bit
of a little mini fail breakout you could
even say um and I believe it it knocks
me out out here and so that trade still
closed up at you know I think two two
times my risk really good profitable
trade right there which is you know a
great growth on a small account now
again to remind you just make sure to
get that PDF in the link below with all
these it'll be really helpful for you to
dive even more into technical analysis
and reading candlesticks which is
crucial for trading this kind of style
check out this video right here I go
even more in depth onto the nuts and
bolts of how reading into the price
movement of the market and it will flush
out these ideas and patterns even more
for you